college of southern nevada students don
their caps and gowns and took to the
stage to graduate
the in-person event which was a great
way for families to celebrate
as we inch closer to normal here in
nevada madison kimbrough joins us live
from sam boyd tonight where that
ceremony took place
madison yeah hey sasha as you can see
they are packing up now as we speak but
many students lost out on the
opportunity
to graduate with their peers last year
but today
students friends and family all gathered
around to celebrate
csn's 2021 graduates
[Music]
this is what i was hoping when i thought
it was only going to be virtual i was
really sad about that
today was a momentous day for students
like kimberly who was just one of
thousands of csn 2021 graduates
who took the stage today to receive
their diploma and certificate
a major difference from last year as
today's graduates got to join their
peers in person
applauding each other for the work they
have accomplished
graduates like adrian feel like all the
hard work he put in
paid off as he is representing his
family in a big way
first of my family to go to college and
it really means a lot that i
that i had the opportunity to go early
and officially go
after high school and work for my degree
this was the college of southern
nevada's biggest class to date as crews
started working at noon
setting everything up and preparing the
stage csn school officials shared just
how many students were graduating today
we have almost 4 thousand students
graduating today
and out of that almost 900 of them are
first-time full-time
full-time students graduate kimberly
king says this means the world to her
after struggling for several years i am
super excited this is this is what
recovery is about this is what college
is about
i'm a recovering addict and i've spent
the last six years building on myself
and to cap off the night a special treat
for students family and staff
lit up the sky
and look at those fireworks well the
ceremony started at 6 30 it ended at 10
o'clock tonight
now masks were required and then
temperature checks were done upon
arrival reporting live madison kimbrough
8 news now